let's go next to Sam from New York City
Sam welcome to the program what's going
on
hey thanks so much I'm certified a
question about you know I need to cover
some of the Trump rallies that Marathon
for unfortunately they're a young kid
you know three four five that are there
and you kind of skip over that part I
agree with that because I really do see
them as victims of uh again a very
narrow media space where they've just
been fed for propaganda
um so what I wonder sort of
theoretically is at what point at what
age in their development do we then sort
of turn and start building them
responsible because I really struggle
with that right you have a
three-year-old I'm not going to blame a
three-year-old for having crumpy views
the big forced to wear like a trumpet
but that three-year-old's gonna grow up
still ingesting the same media diet yeah
so is there like a point where then we
can start holding that former
three-year-old if possible here's why
this is really tough
if we had a system of Education in the
United States where we knew with
confidence Sam that starting in fifth
grade and then definitely by seventh and
eighth grade and a hundred percent in
high school we were really teaching kids
here's how you think for yourself here's
how you think critically here's how you
evaluate claims here's how you do
research Etc if we did that I would be
very comfortable saying to you listen
by the time kids are 15 we can start to
say
you were responsible for the things you
now believe right that would be that's a
hypothetical but the truth is many
schools don't teach this stuff I visited
rural conservative parts of the country
where people's entire kind of
socio-cultural lives revolve around
their churches and the local shooting
range
if that's what they're exposed to until
they're 18 or ever
at I don't know what the answer is
because they sort of are in a bubble
they were born into indefinitely so that
you know blame I don't know about I
don't know about the word blame
necessarily but I think as people get
closer and closer to age 18 I think they
are more and more independent in all
ways and that would be both legally but
also in terms of the things they believe
I mean listen if we're if you look at
kids at 14
they are still very likely to hold the
same political views as their parents
even at 18 that's still the case because
in general people continue to hold the
political views you're more likely to
hold the political views of the family
you were brought up in that that we know
that that that persists so I don't know
when there's a clean break and we say I
mean listen a four-year-old is a
four-year-old they're not thinking for
themselves about politics a 12 year old
might be depending on how they were
brought up a 15 year old should be but
we can't really be sure I don't know the
answer it's it's a very gray area
yeah no that's exactly how I feel um I
appreciate your nuanced thought on it
but I also just close with uh with risk
of causing some controversy my own
belief and where you get the best bagel
in New York City please
all right absolute Bagel 107th and
Broadway I don't know if you're familiar
I I never get out of there I never get
up there all right well if you ever are
I'm telling you it says
darn good bagel I'm telling you I
believe that's only though so be
prepared listen here's the thing
there's hundreds of places with great
Bagels in New York City you know that's
just the reality and and I know I might
be there and there's dozens of places
with great brisket and you know so it's
almost like a little bit of a joke but
where are you on places like for example
Russ and Daughters where like they're
they've become so known and touristy
that it's like yes it's good but like is
it as good as people make it out to be I
I don't know I don't know no you will
never catch me waiting in that like
two-hour line erupting daughters maybe
it's marginally better if someone else
wants to wait for me and let me try a
bite of their pastrami sandwich I'm all
for it but no I avoid all those places
just like I avoid you know Times Square
you know exactly Times Square is just
the worst yep I'm with you all right now
going there all right sorry yeah thank
you take care okay Sam take it Sam shot
out of a cannon on the bagel topic and I
understand it I mean it is one of the
foremost issues that that humanity is
contending with right now